alors le césar du meilleur espoir
féminin est attribué à fatca youssouf
dans mignonne
son passage précoce de l'essence dans
une banque de danseuses de son agent de
manière très adulte avec leur corps
c'est une annonce de réseaux sociaux
qu'elle a repéré à 12 ans le casting de
mignonnes deux mois avant le début du
tournage elle s'est imposée parmi plus
de 400 candidates
de new york times a cassé parmi les 20
meilleurs interprètes de 2020 elle a
aujourd'hui 14 on est allé le première à
remporter cette catégorie alors qu'elle
n'était pas dans la liste des prénommé
choisi au préalable par les directeurs
de casting
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi donc déjà j'aimerais
vraiment remercier tout le monde
donc j'aimerais dire un grand merci à
maimouna de cours et de m'avoir donné ma
chance dans ce film qui vous prenez vous
les âges et à tous et à toute l'équipe
de tournage qui a été là mais côté
j'aime si j'aimerais aussi remercier les
mignonnes qui était avec moi pendant
tout le film et c'est vraiment grâce à
elle que j'ai pu passer un agréable
tournage même si c'était ma première
expérience je suis vraiment honoré
d'être ici
j'aimerais aussi remercier tout
particulièrement mes parents et ma maman
qui est dans la salle
je vois là je suis vraiment
reconnaissante et j'aimerais dire à
toutes les personnes de mon âge qui
aimerait se lancer dans le cinéma ou
même s'ils ont une passion de suivre
leurs rêves car c'est le plus important
merci à tous merci bravo